remember that
major netflix deal meghan markle and
prince harry signed
we're a fantastic team we know we are
yeah well e.t has learned that the royal
family
is not happy with the move it's been
complicated
the royals are concerned about how the
deal may play out as
everyone agreed to a one-year review
period for the couple's exit from their
royal duties
harry and meg only transitioned to their
new non-royal life
just six months ago additionally et has
learned that there have been some raised
eyebrows about how the attention on the
new deal
could distract from the work of other
senior members of the families
[Music]
spoke to royal expert katie nicole about
this latest update
i do think there are some members of the
institution
um who are concerned who are concerned
that the couple are going to
cash in on their royal connections that
they might be under pressure
from netflix to stray into other
territory
but sources close to the couple tell me
that they are very
adamant that anything and everything
they do is very much going to be in a
respectful tone
to the queen to the monarchy and very
much on their missions
megan and harry stepped back as senior
royals at the end of march
we are taking a leap of faith so thank
you for giving me the courage
to take this next step a decision which
was made
in part to allow them financial freedom
cue
a massive netflix deal
magic the duke and duchess of sussex
locked down the new development earlier
this month
they will be producing films and shows
for the streaming service which will
include
scripted series docuseries documentaries
features and even children's programming
megan and harry are also planning to
produce content that highlights
issues that their non-profit archwell is
focused on
they're also committed to promoting
diversity at their production company
already in the works a nature docu
series and
an animated series that celebrates women
so i think we're going to see content
focus on their passion projects
conservation
mental health and women's rights civil
rights these are all the sorts of things
that we're going to see within their
programming i think anyone that's
expecting a reality tv
series about the royals is going to be
sorely disappointed i wouldn't be at all
surprised to see harry
and meghan narrating perhaps a
documentary series
possibly even this series which has been
greenlit
which is an innovative nature
documentary series i'm told
it's unclear how much the megawatt deal
is worth
neither netflix nor the couple has
revealed the number
but in a statement the couple did say
this about the new venture
quote our lives both independent of each
other
and as a couple have allowed us to
understand the power of the human spirit
of courage resilience and the need for
connection
through our work with diverse
communities and their environments
to shining a light on people and causes
around the world
our focus will be on creating content
that informs but also
gives hope
you